I think you should chase what energizes
you everyone talks about passion legacy
purpose yeah the one word to pay
attention to his energy
the only kind of force that will truly
create change in your life is you the
internal kind of force whatever it is
that you're doing right now it's leading
to the thing that you dream of doing
wanna soar get a mentor
[Music]
hey it's Evan Carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you you've
got Michael Jordan level talent at
something so today let's learn from one
of the best Mel Robbins and some of her
best motivation mentor me Mel
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one chase energy I think you should
chase what energizes you everyone talks
about passion legacy purpose yeah the
one word to pay attention to his energy
I love that that's it let's simplify
this okay so whatever energizes you
naturally expands you feels like
possibility is exciting to do it may be
scary that doesn't matter it has to do
with how it makes you feel right when
you were in your 20s money made you feel
good it expanded you it energized you
chasing the money that was the game that
was your passion that was your proof
there's nothing wrong with that nothing
wrong with that and I particularly want
to say that to the women that are well
yeah because it is socialized into women
not to chase success like that not to go
after the money and so if what energizes
you is amassing wealth go for it but
what happened and and the reason why I
say that is because people talk about
the word passion
yeah or purpose right and the truth is
it's not a person place or a thing
it's not it is the feeling of being
expanded and energized right if you're
pursuing your passion it means that you
wake up every day and our energized so
instead of trying to think what's my
purpose what's my passion was my purpose
what's my passion
Wow yeah instead of thinking like that I
want you instead to ask yourself what's
what could I do today that would
energize me what energizes me if it's
making money
figure out how to make money if it is
making a difference figure out how to
make a difference it could be in any
single shape or form but if it energizes
you that's what you need to follow and
what happens is that passion also
because it's energy it dissipates over
time because when you first start making
money it's thrilling yeah
thrilling there is nothing more
exhilarating than making your first
million yeah nothing more exhilarating
but what happens is once you learn how
to do something once you can do it over
and over again and so it starts to
become routine yeah which means it's no
longer energizing right which is why
every entrepreneur out there goes
through the mode of chasing the money
and then you hit the money that you need
to make then you're like I'm not the
hell yeah do that
finally I you know I did that yes yeah
and it's because you were energized by
the money and now you're not yeah now
you got to be energized by the next
thing rule number two
take action one night Chris have gone to
bed I had been struggling struggling
struggling we still had all the same
problems I we stalled a lien on the
house still facing bankruptcy still
fighting like crazy I was still
unemployed
he still they still haven't figured out
like the solution yet for the business
and I was about to turn off the TV and
there on the the TV there was this
rocket launching and I thought oh my
gosh it I am gonna launch myself out of
bed like a rocket ship like NASA right
here had launched me out of that bed and
I'm gonna move so fast that I don't
think hmm I'm gonna beat my breed now
here's a really interesting point I
talked a lot about your instincts and
inner wisdom and we can get into this a
little bit later but a lot of us talk
about the fact that you have a gut
feeling but what all this research that
I've done for the book and all the
speaking that I do what I've discovered
that's fascinating is actually when you
set goals when you have an intent
on something that you want to change
about your life your brain helps you
what it does is it opens up a checklist
and then your brain goes to work trying
to remind you yeah of that intention
that you set and it's really important
to develop the skill and I say that word
purposefully the skill of knowing how to
hear that inner wisdom and that
intention kicking in and leaning into it
quickly
so for me my brain saying that's it
right there move as fast as a rocket Mel
I wanted to change my life and I think
most people that are miserable or that
are that are really like dying to be
great and dying to have more we want to
change we want to live a better life we
want to create more for our families we
want to be happier the the desire is
there again it's about how do you go
from knowledge to actions so the first
thing in the story that's important is
realizing that the answer was in me and
my mind was telling me pay attention I
could have also been the Bourbon anyway
the next morning the alarm goes off and
I pretended NASA was there it's a
stupidest story I literally went five
four three two one I counted out loud
and then I stood up and I'll never
forget standing there in my bedroom it
was dark it was cold it was winter in
Boston and for the first time in three
months I had beaten my habit of hitting
the snooze button I couldn't believe it
and I thought wait a minute counting
backwards that is the dumbest thing I've
ever heard in my entire life
well the next morning I used it again
and it worked the next morning I used it
again and it worked the next morning I
used it again and it worked and then I
started to notice something really
interesting there were moments all day
long all day long just like that
five-second moment in bed where I knew
knowledge what I should do and if I
didn't move within five seconds my brain
would step in and talk me out of it
every human being has a five-second
window might even be shorter for you you
have about a five-second window in which
you can move from idea to action before
your brain kicks into full gear and
sabotages any change in behavior because
remember your brain is wired to stop you
from doing things that are uncomfortable
or uncertain or scary it's your job to
learn how to move from those ideas that
could change everything into acting on
them also if you want to have more
confidence check out my 254 series
they're free the links are in the
description below our minds are designed
to stop you at all costs from doing
anything that might hurt you you might
want to get honest with yourself like
instead of doing this via billionaire or
do this do you really because you can
make it happen
you actually can look at all the idiots
that are making money you can make money
if you didn't give what anybody else
thought what's the thing you would love
to be doing with your life rule number
three stop waiting for permission a lot
of you feel stuck because you're waiting
for some kind of external force to
either push you and pressure you to
change and to be great and to be amazing
or you're waiting for somebody to give
you permission you're either sitting
back because you need some sort of
external motivation from somebody that's
gonna push you or praise you or pressure
you in order to change or some life
circumstance like maybe in your past
you've experienced trauma or you face
something really scary and that was the
thing that made you change and then the
second thing that people wait around for
is permission look those may or may not
come in your life if you are somebody
that is sitting around waiting for some
external force to come and do the work
for you that is such a losing bet it's
unbelievable maybe you'll get lucky
maybe somebody will come but more than
likely no one is coming
the only kind of force that will truly
create change in your life is you the
internal kind of
I hate to say it but for those of you
that feel really really stuck and you
keep thinking that somebody's got to
pick me or somebody's going to discover
me or somebody's got to give me
permission to write this book it's it's
ridiculous this is external versus
internal force
and what you have to figure out if
you're stuck is are you the kind of
person that is guilty of needing wanting
and waiting for external forces people
an event some outside force to kick you
in the ass so that you'll finally do the
stuff that you've been dreaming about
doing I want to tell you something no
one's coming no one the people in life
that get what they want are the ones
that aren't waiting for an external
force to validate their dreams to
inspire them to give them permission
it's the people that realize that
success but happiness that control it
comes from the internal force and what
is the internal force it's you it's you
it's you being able to realize that no
one's going to do the work for you it's
you realizing that you're never gonna
feel ready
in fact even as you start working toward
the things that you really want to do
you're definitely not going to feel
ready and you're gonna feel outside your
comfort zone and that's normal when you
start to feel like you're stretching
yourself and you're sticking your
scrawny neck out there and you're taking
some risks that's amazing cuz you're
growing rule number four hone your
skills I want to talk to those of you
that are working toward your dreams
whatever it is that you're doing right
now it's leading to the thing that you
dream of doing and you're not going to
progress until you get the skills and
the experience that you need at the
level that you're at I guarantee you
even if you're working at a front desk
job at a local gym you're learning
customer service you need to learn that
kind of stuff before you can launch your
own business for me in order to be an
incredible speaker that can command the
stage with 3,000 people in the audience
for an entire hour I first had to learn
how to have the courage to speak up and
have hard conversations in my life then
I had to learn how to speak up in a
small meeting then I had to learn how to
speak up you know in a church basement
then I had to learn how to give a little
bit of a talk at a brown-bag luncheon
then I had to learn how to stand on a
slightly bigger stage
if you're frustrated with where you are
right now because you've got these big
dreams and you think you're really far
away here's one way that you can
continue to be patient and you can milk
wherever you're at to help you build the
skills and the experience that you need
as you climb toward the thing that you
want ask yourself what is it that I am
learning what's the skill that I'm
honing by sitting here at this front
desk job or driving this uber or lyft
vehicle what am i learning that I'm
gonna take with me on my journey to do
that next big thing because I guarantee
you there's something in the minutiae of
what you're doing right now that you are
developing an expertise and a skill
around that you're gonna need as you
launch yourself towards the next thing I
knew number five the last one before a
very special bonus clip is do it anyway
do it anyway is a mindset trick that you
can use when you start to feel excuses
rolling up it works a lot like the
five-second rule so you have said to
yourself okay I'm gonna talk to my boss
today about that thing that I've been
avoiding talking to them about or maybe
you've said something like I'm gonna go
to the gym today or tomorrow whatever
and then the moment comes where you've
got to have that conversation or the
moment comes where it's time to pack up
your bag and leave your desk and go to
the gym and what always happens you
don't feel like it I bet there are
plenty of you watching that have made a
commitment that yeah I'm not gonna have
a drink today and then guess what
happens when you get home you don't feel
like not drinking you feel like having a
drink and so here's what do it anyway
has done for me the idea that I just do
it anyway has pushed me to realize and
to recognize that there are a lot of
moments when there are things in my life
that I really want to do I need to do I
should do but when the moment comes I
don't feel like it and so I pull out
this idea of you know what I'm just
gonna do it anyway it's raining outside
I said I would go for a short run I
don't feel like it
I'm gonna do it anyway it's six o'clock
in the morning I'm tired it's cold I
laid out my yoga clothes but now I don't
feel like it what do I do I do it anyway
when you start to say to yourself I'm
gonna do it anyway what happens is
something really cool you acknowledge
that there are feelings that you have
that are trying to swoop in and hijack
you you acknowledge them and you
basically say guess what I'm gonna do it
anyway now I have a special bonus clip
from Mel on how to control how you live
that I think you can enjoy but before
that it's time for the three point
landing questions let's go from just
watching a video to taking action here
we go question number one what do you
need to just do anyway number two what
decision do you need to stop waiting for
permission to do and number three how
can you chase energy this week and if
you promise to take action after
watching this video we don't just watch
videos we do something about it
give me a hash tag believe down the
comments make that promise to yourself
and then get to work you know I'm always
looking for new ways to explain the
power of the five-second rule and the
power of five-second decisions and I
read something that Tim Ferriss said
that really resonated with me and he had
this one line buried in a podcast
somewhere that just jumped out and it's
it's it's stuck and what he said is he
said something about how there's a gap
between the world and the things that
trigger you and your response and your
entire life is that gap when you start
to this is not what he said he I kind of
identified this gap and I of course
intrinsically was like well absolutely
that's the five-second window between
instinct or stimulus and your reaction
and when you start to understand that
your whole life plays out in this
five-second gap and that there's a gap
that's five seconds long between fear
and courage and there's a gap that's
five seconds long between self-doubt and
confidence that is your life and what's
super cool about understanding that your
whole life is in
this gap is it so small everybody that
you have the ability to control it
life's always gonna throw triggers at
you and there will always be all kinds
of cool things that inspire you your
wisdom and you get to choose what
happens in that gap do you succumb to an
excuse or do you push yourself forward
when you start to speak up in business
you'll be shocked at how you start to
speak up and your relationships when you
start to make hard phone calls whether
it's in a selling situation you'll be
surprised at how you'll start to close
the gap and have hard conversations in
your personal life and so that gap is
everywhere and it's the same everywhere
and when you start to go to work in
controlling how you live in that gap
between stimulus or idea and your
response that's where the magic is
if you want to know how mal Robbins
deals with stress and depression check
out the video right there next to me I
think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there
it's really easy to isolate yourself
what I want you to do is I want you to
actually make a more concerted effort to
re-engage